so und ich mache es kurz ich meine these
ist jeder muss jetzt herrschen
das ist die these und ich glaube man
versteht ja auch namen nicht mehr viel
zeit und ich höre keine widerworte also
bestärkt sie auch bestehen es war die
grösste synthese die jeweils zwei tage
lang herum reden es war der wohl gemeint
ist ich bin wirklich ich bin ich bin
begeistert davon wie geholfen wird rwe
die das organisierte was jeder die frage
der zukunft ist also nicht bist du
geimpft sondern wie hast du geholfen ja
zusätzlich zum thema bist du geimpft ist
das darf man ja nicht ganz vergessen
dass das thema auch noch gibt aber ja
ich finde ich finde jeder hat es auch
vor allem jeder kann helfen es wege gibt
es noch mal für die zuschauer dazu
helfen ob das jetzt geldspenden sind
sachspenden sind es kann auch einfach
sein dass man sagt okay ich verzichte
auf einen coffee to go morgens und das
mache ich jetzt eine woche lang und
dafür ständig das geld was ich da
gespart habe zum beispiel oder ich guck
was im kleiderschrank ab weil sie nicht
brauche gibt das eine oder andere teil
bei uns frauen solche sachen und da
glaube ich daran jeder jetzt mal ganz
kurz zu hause überlegen worauf kann ich
verzichten was könnte ich gehen lassen
und das dann zu einer bestimmten
sammelstelle bringen zum beispiel neben
der spenden und ich finde ein
spendenaufruf so wichtig dass es hier
auch schon bei ein herz für kinder gegen
hergemacht und dazu aufgerufen im
gespräch mit janina kirsch du hast ja
selber kinder charlotte und ich habe
mich gefragt wie erklärt man kindern
denn jetzt eigentlich dass krieg
herrscht bekommen die da schon mit oder
wie macht man das als mutter es ist ein
wahnsinnig schwieriges thema weil ich
eigentlich dachte wir hätten damit
abgeschlossen das ist das nicht gibt das
wurde mir immer von der politik erzählt
das ist jetzt keine kriege mehr diese
richtung geben wird jetzt haben wir doch
nämlich ein und ich habe das versucht
sehr klar und strukturiert zu erklären
ich kann den meinen kindern natürlich
nicht verheimlichen dass krieg
schrecklich ist dass es brutal ist und
dass menschen sterben aber ich kann es
versuchen anhand eines beispiels zum
beispiel am schulhof in der streit
entsteht dann kommen die erzieher und
schlichten das ist die nato also ich
versuche so ein bisschen das ganze so
sachlich aufzuarbeiten aber natürlich
bleiben die ängste natürlich bleiben die
fragen warum darf er das wir warum macht
er das und müssen wir angst haben hier
zu hause ist mama sind wir hier sicher
wo gehen wir denn hin wenn wir hier
wegmüssen und ich glaube tatsächlich
dass es auch okay ist als mama auch zu
sagen ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es
wirklich nicht